LIKE  TRYO
SKCARTOONIST STEVE B
D THAT.
THE PANDEMIC PTED HI
DRAWS HURE.
FOR SOANWH START WHEN CARICATU E
DAYN THPICKED U
STORY TO TE WHICNAMES AND  LET N
HAINNOT OUT OF HIS HUCH  A COVID
G N ALABAMA.
ING YOUNG PEOPLE HER HOSPITALANR
SONE OF THE LASTHE 'RE OFTEN OF
WOULD BEG FOR THE  SHE HAD TNYBY
>> HE'S L
, LIVI DYIN AMERICA.D IN A
DO THI M>> THAT'S MAYBE ORE
CAN THE
BECAUSE
ABT S VICTIMHOOD.
ERIC
HE IS.
HIE DRAWING HIM.OR Y '
HIT'S ENJOYABL WAY IN
YOU FEEL THAU HAVEG THAT'S GONE
ST
E LE
W LOOK
AND HE LOOKED AFTEE ,
AND 'SROUBLES
MAERG VARIT DEATHS O
FLOYD,R AND SO
MANY MORE.
OOK ON DARKER
FEK ON THE S. CAPIT OPOLICERE S
IMAGE.
A FACE, A THING THATT'GOING WEH
LI
NG INT Y
INTO THE
CHARACTER, BUTHE FEELING THE
HAS.
THE CONTOURS OF THE FAC INT'S
TOE VEH ITLL
CONTINUE T.HEN TO EXPREUTABOUWHT